so a few years ago I remember  telling me that you were in a ph.d  program at Harvard but you left to take  over the family business tell us a  little bit about that and and with at  which point then you refocus your energy  is elsewhere I found it was very easy to  be a student I was the I felt like I was  the luckiest person in the world to have  the opportunity to read to study to ask  questions to meet the most interesting  people I could imagine meeting and then  my family at a small business it was  struggling and for the first time in my  life I heard fear in my parents voice  fear of not being able to afford to live  in our home to be able to afford to pay  for dinner to not to know what to do  next and I thought I might be able to  help I was lucky to be able to help and  have the opportunity to leave sort of  the lofty world of the ivory tower to  something very very mundane and keeping  some people employed my family included